foreign
Lee is in Denver hey Lee what's up
hi so my question is how do you prepare
for what feels like a Perpetual
financial disaster it's like I get
through step one and start working on
step two and then something comes up and
step one is totally back to zero
okay
sounds like a lot of drama
um yeah Perpetual financial disaster is
not one I've ever heard that's
interesting so uh you've you just had
you you you can't seem to get ahead
because you get keep getting kicked off
the ladder is that what you're saying
Kinda Yeah Yeah so what happened give me
like two or three of the examples
okay so it really starts back in
November my boyfriend broke up with me
and moved out and I was stuck paid for
um the place I live by myself which is
1600 a month have you moved and then uh
no and the reason I'm not moving is I
did find a roommate but my landlord
actually really likes me as a tenant and
said that he would drop my rent two
hundred dollars if I signed another
lease come May
what do you make
um so last year I made about 60 000
right now it's looking like way less
than that because I started a new job
um pursuit of a career instead of a dead
end job this is not a Perpetual
financial disaster this is Perpetual bad
decisions
yeah I mean the other thing that is
really
um
causing a financial disaster is I got a
car a year and a half ago I've been
working on paying it off because it does
have high interest on it and it got
stolen two weeks ago so it took away
praise God that it have insurance
I did yeah you got out of the high
interest rate
they're going to pay it off right
no so I'm upside down in the car and
because of how essential my car is
um they're not totaling it they're
working a lot of damage they found it
the next day
um so I'm still stuck with the car
um
and what I do with it is I mean I travel
for my I am in healthcare I do sleep
studies but I also drive for Uber on the
side to kind of supplement what I'm
making in healthcare
so how much do you own This Disaster of
a car
how much are they going to give you for
the damage
um 13 I think
about 3 500 is the damage estimate on it
so not enough to Total out the car
okay
what's your interest rate
um
sorry
so I again I'll repeat myself you have
not had Perpetual financial disasters
you've had Perpetual bad decisions
okay 21 is in the stupid Zone signing up
for a lease you can't afford with your
live-in boyfriend who takes office in
the stupid Zone
you set yourself up for these things
these weren't things that happened to
you you caused them
okay okay so that if you want to stop
having them then that's the that's the
way to fix it is we've got to start
thinking with a clearer head so what you
what if I woke up in your shoes what I'm
going to just put 3 500 on this car and
I'm going to work day and night night
and day have absolutely no life until I
get this car paid off and I'm going to
move out of this stupid apartment you
can't afford with a roommate that isn't
going to pay that's your next bad
decision and get you something very very
cheap that you can afford because if you
had a lower rent and no car payment and
you work like a crazy person you could
have some money
and to that end I'd stop doing the Uber
because you're just you're putting more
miles on your car you can find other
hourly jobs right now that can pay
better than Uber and allow you to stock
up more money and not be causing you
know damage to the car and all of the
gas money you can do better on that
second third job like give them an
example Ken well Target at 20 bucks an
hour so yeah take take a big box store
like a Walmart or Target you just look
at 17 to 20 bucks an hour you know and
you're pulling extra hours and work all
the time
as a waitress let me tell you
restaurants are dying to find people you
go in good high-end right a good nice
restaurant where you're gonna get good
tips yep I mean you're just you're
making more of your time you're not
driving that car I want you working so
much you are freaking exhausted and you
have no time to party right
yeah and I was doing that last year
um I was doing 80 hours a week in
security and then security didn't pay
anything to another
oh yeah I was making I think 18 hours
during security much better than I
thought okay good
well you've done it before you can do it
again but this is going to be a shorter
time span and you're coming out on the
other side debt free and walking the
baby steps and now you've got Financial
Freedom I mean you should not ever have
a boyfriend leave and leave you an alert
ever again yeah because you've already
done that one once you're gonna have to
do that one again uh you should not ever
sign up for a 21 interest rate on a car
ever again you've already done that once
you never have to do that one again see
my goal when I was young Lee I did a lot
of really stupid things that's how I can
recognize this I mean I got a PhD in
Dumb I've done every stupid thing you
can do but my goal was to never do the
same stupid thing twice
and so once you've got a whole bunch of
stupid things on your resume already and
you never do them again you start to
become what they call Wise because all
the stupid stuff's more in your rear
view mirror that's what happened to me
yeah and here's what we know people ask
my advice I know amazing but you know
here's the deal you will change when
your pain forces you to or your desired
future inspires you to and I think in
this case you got to take both of those
the pain and the desired future for a
better life and put them together and
get after it bust it what you're going
crazy yeah making a lot of money and
doing nothing to spend it clear this car
up get out of that lease get you a place
where you I know your landlord likes you
I bet he likes you that's yeah I bet he
does
most landlords again no he wants to do
her a favor for her to sign a longer
lease yeah he's such a nice guy I'm
gonna help you out here
yeah uh nope